Ryan Reynolds is one sneaky rascal.
In response to a fan on Twitter asking whether
it was okay to screen Reynolds' hit Deadpool
for his four-year old, the star offered a
bit of tongue-in-cheek advice: lie your face
off, a tack he claimed to have taken with
his own daughters.
Reynolds is known far and wide for two things:
inhabiting the character of Deadpool to an
extent which may not exactly be healthy, and
his Twitter feed, which is one of the greatest
compendiums of hilarity on the entire internet,
at least according to his superfans.
The latest example of this was prompted by
Twitter user @jediminndtrick, who asked:
"RYAN I HAVE AN IMPORTANT QUESTION I NEED
AN ANSWER TO RIGHT TF NOW!!!
My son is 4, he loves Marvel, I'm dying to
show him Deadpool but I can't decide if I
should or not.
Helpasistahout!!!!!!!!"
Reynolds immediately leaped into action, doubtless
convinced by all of those caps that this was,
indeed, a question that needed to be answered
with all due haste.
His advice was as awesome as it was hilariously
irresponsible:
"No.
Put on Spider-Man (from 2002) and tell him
it's Deadpool.
It's what I do with my kids.
Remember to look him straight in the eye when
you lie.
Good luck."
So, apparently, Reynolds' children, 4-year-old
James and 2-year-old Ines, seen here in 2016,
think he is Spider-Man, which is a pretty
neat trick, if you ask us.
Sure, there are a few similarities between
the costumes of the wall-crawler and the Merc
with a Mouth, but how on Earth does Reynolds
explain why he looks exactly like Tobey Maguire
when the mask comes off?
We knew kids could be gullible, but that's
just ridiculous.
Of course, a quick perusal of Reynolds' previous
tweets quickly reveal that his musings on
parenting, and well, most topics, are never,
ever, to be taken seriously.
Here's a quick selection of our favorites:
"My daughter's only 6 months old and already
drawing.
I'd hang it on the fridge but honestly, it's
absolute garbage."
"I'm teaching my daughter that the sun goes
down each night because it's mad at her.
Probably gonna write a book on parenting at
some point."
And, our all-time favorite:
"Totally caved and tossed my daughter the
keys to the car.
She looked really happy as they bounced off
her tiny infant face."
Obviously, Reynolds is a guy who loves his
family and screwing with people in equal measure.
Soon, he'll have another unsuspecting youngster
to torment: he and his wife Blake Lively are
expecting their third child any old time now.
Little does the new arrival know that it's
going to have Deadpool…er, Spider-Man…for
a dad.
Reynolds had better hope that his children
never have occasion to meet Tobey Maguire,
or they're going to have a lot of uncomfortable
questions.
At any rate, the cinematic fate of Deadpool
is still very much up in the air following
Disney's acquisition of the film and television
assets of Fox Studios.
Although it's understandable that the character's
R-rated antics might be a tough fit for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, 2016's Deadpool
and 2018's Deadpool 2 combined to rake in
over $1.5 billion dollars worldwide, and the
House of Mouse is unlikely to put such a proven
cash cow out to pasture.
The rumor mill insists that not only is Deadpool
3 in the works, but that there are plans to
weave the character into the fabric of the
MCU by way of multiple cameos in Marvel Studios'
upcoming films and television series.
Unfortunately, with talks between Marvel and
Sony Pictures having recently broken down,
it's looking increasingly likely that fans
will never get to see the onscreen pairing
that once seemed inevitable: Reynolds' Deadpool
and Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
"You don't even know he looks like.
What if he's like, seriously burned?"
"I wouldn't care.
I would still love him for the person he is
on the inside."
Then again, from Reynolds' point of view,
this might be a good thing.
When his kids get a little bit older, perhaps
he can show them Spider-Man: Homecoming, or,
as we call it, "Deadpool in high school."
"They let you throw parties, you know?
My parents are...dead."
Boy, are those kids ever going to grow up
confused.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.